welcome to this video playing I guess
this is just 22 or double I whatever
okay well chef stick stick with the
thing that I know but the Queen e7 is a
recent addition to my check ideas here
the idea is after Bishop g2 I have 90
form until black switches to a d5 set up
which is quite interesting as the depot
near the sea pawn is really hanging in a
way white needs to think about this okay
he decides to do sacrifice yeah possible
but it's not so easy to get it back 95
as possible which leads to a very
interesting type of porn structure okay
okay so he's playing it in the name
aggressive fashion and the center yeah
I'd like to I'd like to play Knight
takes the form and I takes d4 Knight
takes e4 e5 but he's got the fleshy move
knight c6 available
does he i also have 'if I've yep
interesting 'if I've d5 should reform
okay very very interesting very
interesting way to play Bishop g4
intending to take an ID form Queen III
Bishop f3 takes c6 I can take f1 yeah I
should be okay yeah interesting that
should be should be quite ok for black
eye I assume if I get the night to d4
I'm all for threatening 94 uh-huh but
here what about if I take wait if i take
f3 can you take these I don't think so I
mean this Bishop takes 95 is a simple
tactic winning winning me upon I was I
wasn't taking on c6 was what irritated
me and this is two pounds now
yeah and still night to deform the the
great night hmm okay and its really
getting this back that's not that's not
good I mean not not a big problem but
okay yeah I don't want to play some
crazy stuff like 95 just I just want to
want to be be solid here yeah right
knight on d4 is just just okay with
Wonder one point is is perfectly enough
hmm i can trade or i can give this check
here check and 92 this isn't this just
winning get another check with this with
this double the tech double the check on
b4 and c4
yeah this is a pony I really want to
take as he has some no one compensation
whatsoever I I can also take the bishop
here white resigns yeah this was
somewhat of an opening disaster the
whole line is not easy to play i really
i don't know it really i was thinking
about them analyzing the Zipit you for
Brooke th this this looks a bit
uncomfortable this this rook Queen issue
on the default and this this is probably
not really great probably rupee a 10 p-5
is also move 95 is what the compass
giving this makes sense yeah definitely
yeah well this is quite okay for white
actually now my night does not have any
anything grade yeah something if I take
for example you will get this
and why does definitely not worse maybe
miss it I don't know I don't know if it
is better home now but he definitely
must play 95 and after this Bishop g4 is
already in trouble and this is losing
really an idea is even stronger maybe
but okay this is just a pawn for
absolutely nothing yet another pawn yeah
the comp wants to play Knight a5 just
keep the porn yeah I had the suspicion
that probably I can just do that but
this is a very comfortable position
you've got still the pawn it is this
porn which is controlling controlling
opponent squares fantastic light on
deform and I have an easy plan route d6
route 28 and exchange on the default
winning the endgame yeah this is
blundering another pony should do this
but this is just two points now ok
thanks for watching